c'est la vitrine canadiennes à
l'étranger un imposant parcs immobiliers
répartis dans plus d'une centaine de
pays
ambassade chancellerie et résidences
pour le personnel diplomatique
appartenant au canada où louis par le
gouvernement si je me rappelle bien
c'est près de 3,5 milliards en actifs un
énorme portefeuille géré par le
ministère des affaires étrangères mais
une astuce politique hypothèque sa
valeur c'est impensable dans le domaine
immobilier d'agir comme ça parce que le
risque est trop élevé si c'est la
sécurité
là effectivement c'est assez c'est assez
grave
l'histoire commence il ya plus de trois
ans quand une équipe de fonctionnaires
des affaires étrangères travaillent
d'arrache-pied à préparer un plan
d'investissement pour bien gérer son
portefeuille immobilier
jusque là rien d'anormal parce que sans
ce document clé le ministère ne peut
savoir où mettre ses priorités et
engager ses fonds or une fois prêt ce
document n'a jamais été remis au conseil
du trésor comme l'exigent la politique
du gouvernement établi par les
conservateurs eux mènent au nom de la
saine gestion
on a les mains dit mais c'est plutôt une
frustration qui existe à cause qu'on
sait qu'on a les stands pour satisfaire
les exigences des sources confirment
lorsqu'il était ministre les affaires
étrangères john baird a volontairement
conservé le document depuis au-moins
avril 2012 sachant que l'absence d'un
plan d'investissement approuvés dans le
conseil du trésor permettrait de
menotter son ministère en matière de
dépenses de mettre de côté des centaines
de millions de dollars
on en a une bonne façon de prioriser en
inde est bon ben ça les choses comme ça
mais on n'a pas les autorités qui
viendrait que je crois qu'il y a un
malaise énorme dans le musée affaires
étrangères à l'heure actuelle des
documents obtenus par radio canada en
vertu de la loi d'accès à l'information
démontrent un mécontentement
une inquiétude grandissante au sein du
ministère
même si la vente d'une partie des
résidences officielles génère des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de dollars les affaires étrangères sont
privés de ses enfants alors que ces
sommes devraient être normalement
réinvesti dans le parc immobilier
elles sont plutôt acheminés vers le
fonds consolidé qui sert à éponger le
déficit de plus en retenant les dépenses
le gouvernement crée un retard massif
dans les travaux d'entretien et de mise
à niveau des édifices le dépenser un
poste à jeunes on facilite ne saurait
qu'elles ont tous et toutes de dix rangs
mondiaux ça va vers le québec budgétaire
car dans le fond on fait une cachette en
n'ayant pas de plan d'investissement ont
ce qu d argent pour faire des mises à
niveau mais ceara là n'étant pas
dépenser retour mal fonds consolidé donc
je ne fais partie du beau-parent très
andré chagnon est un expert en gestion
immobilière
si on prend pas soin maintenant ça va
être encore pire dames et est souvent la
facture votre et les quadruples et en
danse et ça peut être le thoër s'appelle
l'ascenseur sap est n'importe quoi la
laine au niveau du reste car on joue
avec le feu
il sent ne s'arrête pas là des sources
confirment à radio canada kerri
manoeuvre orchestrée par jean band ont
même bloqué l'aboutissement de projets
considérés prioritaires
il touche à la sécurité des diplomates
et du personnel à islamabad
kaboul et port au prince trois endroits
considérés à très haut risque pour
répondre à des besoins urgents
la direction du ministère réclame l
approbation de la construction de
nouveaux complexes diplomatique au
pakistan et en afghanistan
alors qu'en haïti le personnel devait
obtenir des logements neufs à côté
l'ambassade
la solidité des maisons présentement
louis restent incertaines même cinq ans
après le tremblement terre
quand on commence à bloquer les
approbations pour des projets qui nous
paraissent essentiels en particulier
celui de la sécurité de nos employés
l'enseignement est ce que c'est une
question d'attitude est une question de
perception du rôle de la diplomatie et
de nos diplomates des terrains ont été
achetés dans les trois pays en 2009 et
2010 mais rien n'a bougé depuis
alors si vous me dites confrontons fait
des coupes aussi dans des décisions qui
finalement avec la sécurité ça ne
m'étonne pas ça fait partie d'un
ensemble d'attitude à l'égard du
ministère et ça monsieur perdent en a
été l'artisan par excellence un portrait
qui détonne avec les affirmations de
l'ancien ministre baird
questionné sur la sécurité des missions
à l'étranger
voici ce qu'il répondait à la chambre
des communes en novembre dernier
le gouvernement a beau se présenter en
champion de la sécurité et affirmé que
les menaces sont plus que jamais réel
cet ancien diplomate qui a servi sous
les gouvernements melon et et chrétiens
lens est mise en garde dans le contexte
actuel les ambassades peuvent devenir
facilement des cibles on y visaient un
fait combien de fois qu'on se fait dire
à certains amis à nous quelques on est
sur leur liste
si on est sur le relais ce n'est pas
nécessairement sur la colline
parlementaire
partout et un drapeau du canada ça
attire l'attention
ces révélations ce soir céline une
réponse écrite ce soir une réponse très
générale de la part du bureau du nouveau
ministre les affaires étrangères ramener
curseur qui nie que de fonctionner comme
ça constitue une mesure de réduction des
coûts ou encore une façon d'équilibrer
budget mais céline je dois vous préciser
que la plupart de nos questions sont
restées sans réponse de la part du
cabinet du ministre y compris celles
concernant islamabad caball et port au
prince déjà l'opposition ici qualifie le
gouvernement d' irresponsable ces
révélations placent les conservateurs
sur la défensive
surtout au moment où il fait de la
sécurité une de ses plus grandes
priorités
merci de ces précisions marque